[Música]
la lucha contra el cambio climático es
el llamado que todos los expertos
científicos reiteran cada año en la
Cumbre por el clima sin embargo muchas
veces estos llamados se han vuelto
discursos ambiguos y no se sabe
exactamente Qué acciones son las que hay
que tomar en francés 24 hablamos con Ana
María Durán doctora en física y
especialista en meteorología de la
Universidad de Costa Rica
la lucha climática parece una batalla
colosal Cuáles cree que son las acciones
más importantes a tomar por nuestra
sociedad para frenar el calentamiento
global las acciones más urgentes a nivel
Global en este momento definitivamente
incluyen la reducción de las emisiones
de gases de efecto invernadero
particularmente dióxido de carbono
también el metano y los diferentes
compuestos de bases nitrogenadas en este
caso estamos hablando de cambios
importantes en la maneras de producir
los alimentos es decir los fertilizantes
agroquímicos que se utilizan hay que
repensar la manera de la producción
agrícola también introducir y continuar
las prácticas agrícolas sostenibles es
decir la producción de alimentos en este
momento es una de las de las fuentes más
importantes de contaminación Y por
supuesto la industria que es el
principal emisor en este momento debe
realizarse una serie de normativas que
permitan realmente garantizar que la
industria está reduciendo las emisiones
por otro lado estamos hablando también
del sector transporte donde es muy
urgente reactivar lo que corresponde a
transporte público más eficiente y una
reducción necesaria del uso de
combustibles fósiles también
Respecto a los efectos climáticos que ya
se están notando en algunas partes del
planeta Qué se puede hacer para
contrarrestarlos y para evitar que haya
otros más fuertes lo primero es la
planificación y recordar que además del
cambio climático dentro de los impactos
que tenemos como sequías y eventos
extremos hay una participación de la
variabilidad climática Y entonces la
variabilidad climática En ese sentido
nos da una medida de cómo las acciones
que estamos realizando para mitigar los
impactos de los eventos extremos nos
podrían ayudar a mitigar no impactos
también asociados al cambio climático
cuando hablamos de planificación estamos
hablando de conocer mejor Cuáles son los
procesos y cuál es la dinámica por
ejemplo del establecimiento de los
eventos secos Cuáles son los sectores
que se ven afectados y utilizar las
métricas objetivas que podemos obtener a
partir de diversa información por
ejemplo la meteorológica para preparar
los sectores por ejemplo el sector
agrícola y el sector energético
principalmente en muchos países donde
hay una fuerte producción de energía a
partir de fuentes hidroeléctricas Qué
papel juega la planificación urbana en
un momento en el que muchas ciudades en
distintas partes del mundo ya están
sintiendo efectos fuertes del cambio
climático como mega inundaciones O cada
vez más frecuentes Huracanes cada vez
más frecuentes
uno de los principales impactos que se
tienen en las ciudades son aquellos
asociados con inundaciones muy severas y
en muchos de estos casos ha quedado en
evidencia que el mal manejo territorial
y la mala planificación urbana son
digamos una amenaza adicional al impacto
de estos eventos Y entonces en este
sentido se trata de una planificación
integrada del uso del territorio del
planeamiento de la gestión urbana del
establecimiento de las ciudades de la
planificación también de la ejecución de
obras civiles en los países y al mismo
tiempo también también una planificación
integral con los ministerios de
agricultura por ejemplo
relacionadas a Cómo manejar impactos
sobre el sector productivo
particularmente en este caso
evidentemente la agrícola
Y qué tan importante es migrar por
ejemplo hacia unas prácticas agrícolas
más respetuosas con el medio ambiente
para garantizar la seguridad alimentaria
de las distintas poblaciones Ya se está
observando en algunas regiones del
planeta donde los eventos de sequía
están siendo intensa está siendo más
recurrentes en el tiempo y entonces si
continuamos con las mismas prácticas
productivas y los mismos periodos de
producción en esas regiones ya estamos
no generando un riesgo adicional es
decir si yo sé que en esta región donde
siempre cultivado arroz de repente el
cultivo se empieza a ver afectado de
esta manera y las tendencias ya
observadas no solo las proyectadas sino
las que ya se observan nos indican un
comportamiento de no una un
comportamiento acelerado de la
propagación de la sequía entonces
resulta y sumamente importante que
planifiquemos ahora debemos seguir
cultivando el arroz en esta zona debemos
modificar nuestro método de producción
porque de esta manera podemos también
contribuir con la reducción de los
impactos que vamos a tener sobre la
producción las producciones en los
diferentes en diferentes países y
respecto al trato que se le da a los
suelos en la agricultura Cómo influye
este tratamiento de los suelos en la
crisis climática algo que es muy
importante también por ejemplo en cuanto
a los impactos de la variabilidad del
cambio climático que no siempre los
tenemos muy presentes son los impactos
en la calidad del suelo y entonces
cuando tenemos eventos secos y
posteriormente tenemos eventos de lluvia
intensa vamos a estar aumentando la
erosión del suelo la erosión del suelo
disminuye la calidad del suelo y por lo
tanto son suelos que poco a poco van
perdiendo su capacidad fértil Y eso
también es un impacto quizá un poco
menos considerado sobre la producción de
alimentos y qué recomendaciones existen
para que la agricultura sea más
respetuosa con el medio ambiente y ya
digamos se ha demostrado en diferentes
países a partir estudios que se hayan
venido realizando desde hace décadas
incluso que
los monocultivos tienen una mayor no
están más expuestos son más vulnerables
a los impactos justamente por la poca
capacidad que tenemos de retener agua y
entonces una práctica No una acción
inmediata por ejemplo es considerar que
tengamos zonas reforestadas donde se
encuentran los monocultivos no solamente
generamos sombra que nos ayuda
localmente a mejorar las condiciones de
temperatura para los trabajadores sino
también que al tener árboles con copas
desarrolladas estamos también reduciendo
el impacto directo de la lluvia intensa
sobre el suelo entonces hay toda una
serie de beneficios ecosistémicos que
podemos obtener de incluir en los
cultivos diferentes coberturas vegetales
y eso es lo que no en muchos lugares se
denomina como no agroforestí verdad
desarrollo de agroecosistemas
digamos qué tan importante es hacer
seguimiento a la situación que presenta
el clima en distintas regiones para
poder entender este comportamiento y
actuar en consecuencia si yo quiero
realmente determinar Cómo el clima está
cambiando yo necesito tener mediciones
de los parámetros temperatura
precipitación humedad condiciones del
suelo también que realmente nos permitan
monitorear como es ese cambio en el
tiempo y qué tan rápido está sucediendo
muchas veces se nos olvida que tenemos
necesidad de evidencias para poder
realmente determinar estos cambios es y
además verdad las mediciones que yo no
realizo hoy pues no no existen mañana
para hacer un análisis y entonces es
fundamental el monitoreo y por otro lado
recordar que cuando nos preocupamos
sobre los impactos del cambio climático
y particularmente no sobre la sobre lo
los sistemas en los que vivimos las
personas hay que recordar que el impacto
se compone de muchos elementos por un
lado está el fenómeno hidrometeorológico
que sucede sucederá y cambiará y por
otro lado están las condiciones en las
que nosotros vivimos Y entonces en gran
medida una de las principales acciones
que tenemos que tomar es hacer una
revisión sobre las condiciones de
exposición que tienen las poblaciones es
decir dónde estamos viviendo estamos
viviendo en la Ladera de los ríos
estamos viviendo en zonas de alta
peligrosidad porque todo esto genera un
impacto exacerbado Y entonces estas son
condiciones en las que directamente
nosotros podemos incidir y hacer
modificaciones para reducir estos
impactos que se tienen
y respecto a este trabajo de monitoreo
qué tan importante es que haya
financiamiento por parte de los
gobiernos para que los distintos grupos
de trabajo puedan trabajar
deben los gobiernos asumir compromisos
más fuertes y las políticas nacionales
tienen que ser explícitas en la
inclusión de cómo esta las diferentes
políticas y leyes que se vayan a
desarrollar tomen en cuenta el
fortalecimiento de los sistemas de
monitoreo para las poblaciones no
solitas es muy difícil mantener sus
temas de monitoreo La Academia no el
sector científico sostiene una parte
importante del monitoreo sin embargo el
apoyo gubernamental es esencial para que
esos sistemas de monitoreo puedan ser no
mantenidos y ojalá fortalecidos en el
tiempo
considera usted que todavía hay tiempo
para revertir la crisis climática
tenemos que ver esto de una manera un
poco optimista de que el cambio es
posible y al mismo tiempo tener en
cuenta que las escalas de la tierra son
distintas a las escalas humanas Eso
quiere decir que los resultados de
muchos de los cambios a través de las
acciones que empezamos a implementar hoy
No necesariamente Nosotros los vamos a
ver no
la tierra el sistema climático tiene
pues unas escalas que son más lentas por
decirlo de esa manera Entonces eso
quiere decir que pasan mucho tiempo
pasan en décadas para que los resultados
de esas acciones que se implementan hoy
sean realmente percibibles sin embargo
no acciones de mitigación de los
impactos que se implementan como
mencionábamos anteriormente en el caso
de la planificación agrícola la gestión
energética y también no la evaluación
del manejo de los territorios es así que
las podemos ver de manera inmediata no a
un plazo mucho más corto Entonces yo
creo que el mensaje aquí tiene que ir
orientado a que el hecho de que estas
acciones vayan a tomar bastante tiempo
en ser observadas realmente no es una
razón para quedarnos de brazos cruzados
y no implementarlas porque si no si no
implementamos acciones en este momento
lo que vamos a hacer es ir a grabando el
problema con el tiempo
hasta aquí Este programa especial muchas
gracias Ana María Durán y gracias a
ustedes por acompañarnos sigan con
nosotros para más información en France
24 y France 24.com
[Música]